مع التطور السريع للذكاء الاصطناعي يعمل
علماء من جامعه
الامريكيه على تطوير حواسيب حيويه ذكيه
تحاكي وظائف ملايين من خلايا الدماغ
البشريه
المحاكاه تركز على مجموعه من اليات التعلم
والذاكره في الكائنات العضويه ودمجها
بابتكارات تقنيه لتطوير الذكاء العضوي
بالاعتماد على رقائق السيليكون مستهلكه
طاقه اقل وفق صحيفه البريطانيه
هذه التكنولوجيا بحسب العلماء تهدف لدراسه
الوظائف المعرفيه في الدماغ وتوسيع نطاقها
لتحقيق قدرات حسابيه تستخدم في انشاء
نماذج للذكاء لدراسه اساس الوظائف
الادراكيه للانسان ولا تستخدم هذه
التكنولوجيا فقط في مجالات الذكاء
الاصطناعي بل ايضا تساهم في البحث عن
المواد السامه المسببه للامراض العصبيه
مثل مرض الزهايمر وتحديد علاجاتها